gifts are hard this time of year gifts
are very very very hard to find for the
loved ones but this guy
this guy's got a wine club 69 bucks a
month that's right link in the bio I'm
gonna solve your problem right now the
wine a month club from Wine Library my
dad's business the Gary vaynerchuk one
of the month club comes with uh one to
four bottles a month plus I make a video
every month and talk through the wines
if you want to learn if you want to
surprise somebody in your family if you
just want a really interesting gift that
is Affordable this holiday season the
Gary vaynerchuk wine club at my dad's
store the Wine Library Lincoln bio
you're welcome Dad I love you Sasha I
have a funny feeling a lot of you will
enjoy this it's a fun thing each month I
get a bunch of emails from people that
are in the club laughing at the jokes
the inside Alpha uh sometimes I drop in
there but more importantly discovering
new wines at a ridiculous price hundreds
of dollars worth of wine for 69 a month